every year on lindau island in Germany
dozens of Nobel laureates come to meet
with hundreds of young scientists
it's rare for so many laureates to
gather like this so I'm taking the
opportunity to ask some big questions
about the state of Medicine today to try
to get a picture of health
we're all getting older but which of us
is going to live for how long with all
these Nobel laureates around I'm really
keen to find out what the secret is to a
long and healthy life you can't afford
to preserve every life we don't have
enough money the problem is that the
money is up here
do you think it is possible for us to
continue extending our lifespans
I may be naively optimistic about this
but I believe that the way that
technology is advancing I think it's
quite a possibility maybe not in our
lifetimes but certainly for our
grandchildren perhaps as early as that
do you agree I mean it depends what you
mean by extending lifespan I guess I
feel like we are expanding our lifespan
but maybe not in an extreme way I feel
like people are staying healthier a bit
longer more people will live a bit later
but even people without diseases end up
dying in their early hundreds let's say
and so there seems to be something in
the organism that like a concert of
effects of things that start breaking
down and changing and that means that we
can't really live much more beyond that
at least not as we understand aging
today though of course we don't
understand that much about it
oh it so maybe who knows and should we
be trying to live longer do you think
that that's a worthy aim well it depends
I don't think the focus should be on
that alone I think we should consider
balance between adding years to life and
adding life to years I mean that balance
is very very personal it's worthy goal
only if we can make sure that people
live healthy for a long time that they
can keep working they can keep being
active we don't need several billion
more sick people I'm sure that society
could benefit from having more healthy
people in their later years that have
had the experience of life to have a lot
to contribute to society but not at any
cost
I think but the prospect of living
beyond a hundred is exciting and
shouldn't as many people as possible
should be doing it I believe so I think
that can only really benefit science and
medicine and the group that's increasing
a lot now is the 85 plus and that's
something we should invest a lot in so
they think that we should try to make it
possible to live for longer but only if
it's also a healthier life
but how old is today's well population
anyway there was a presentation at this
year's meeting that caused a bit of a
stir so the laureates to them you will
put questions but I will put questions
to you about global health here's the
first one you can use this device to
answer a B and C what is the life
expectancy of the world population today
is it 50 60 or 70 years
please answer a B or C about life
expectancy you answered let me see you
are like sweet this is the right answer
you see why you think that population
will age because life will be longer
because you don't know how long they
already are the best way to know
something about the future to start
knowing about the present so I got that
totally wrong I met up with Hans Rosling
to get some more insight into the
demographics of our aging world I was
surprising to me and in the lecture that
the world population the average life
expectancy is 70 and is not growing in
the way that we had understood it has
grown already the world has been
immensely successful in removing early
death especially among children
so today Bangladesh have a life
expectancy of 70 and they constitute the
average of the world this is not known
and it's sad that it's not communicate
we're understanding that life is let's
see we'll continue that's the way that
medical science presents the data is
that it has grown and it will continue
to increase we think life expectancy
will increase by 10 years during this
century but that's not so much if you
die when you are 70 or 80 it's not so
much big difference
the big difference is that the child
mortality is down we lose 6 million
children out of the 135 million what is
changing now is that the aging of the
world population is driven by something
else than longer life but even
scientists haven't understood this
because they are limited into their area
of research be it cancer beat immunology
you know beat blood diseases so I used
to explain it like this look here I took
this cup from the breakfast table here
this is the world population there are 2
billions 1/2 to billions below 50 there
is 2 billions fifteen to thirty 1
billion 30 to 45 1 45 to 60 and this is
my cup 60 years old
this is me I'm in here so this is the
world population today 7 billion people
why are these 3 missing is it because
they died no they were never born
because back then when I was born there
were much less women giving birth now
what will happen in the future the big
change that mean aged a rural population
is this the old ones like me will die
sooner or later probably sooner we will
die the rest and you also you can't
believe it today but you will grow older
15 years older and there will be
children we all die
the rest will older and have children
the old die and the rest grow older and
have children did you see the life
didn't get any longer
the children didn't get anymore the
number of children stopped low but we
got 3 billion more in the world because
the children the extra children that
existed have just aged and they have the
population pyramid
now you can see there's a much higher
proportion of all people the average age
get longer but there's a good news for
people like me
there will be longer life also but the
longer life will not add more than
possible
1 billion people however it will add it
among the elite the most privileged in
the richest countries that's why they
are sort of obsessed by living longer
and longer but the big thing in the
world why the world will have more
diabetes more cardiovascular more cancer
is this Philip effect and that it will
be a heavy burden is that it was not
shrinking at the bottom at 89 Nobel
laureate Oliver Smithies is I suppose
part of this older elite I wondered what
his take was on this ageing world what
do you think the challenges are of
having a globally ageing population can
we afford to treat some conditions that
are extremely expensive to treat that
don't have enough benefits you have to
bite the bullet and the bullet is some
treatments are too expensive for the the
reward and so we can't afford as a
community to pay them and and similarly
I suppose the Hans Rosling was making a
point that that not only some treatments
but for some people they shouldn't those
treatments shouldn't be offered and for
other people they should be prioritised
yes I'm afraid it means taking judgments
from that sort because if you have two
people one of my age that would require
a kidney transplant let's say and the
person who is 50 the 50 year old has a
better claim than the 89 year old likely
have a life expectancy all said very
much maybe it might give me a year more
with the 50 year old and my good 40
years more dangerous territory though
isn't it well it's not dangerous it has
to be faced I mean we have to be
realistic about it and that's the
trouble we aren't realistic about it was
sentimental and we say everybody has a
right to life and Tom which is true but
you can't afford to preserve every life
we don't have enough money I mean how
would you feel if the focus of medical
science shifts and we're not focusing
any longer on this
how does what does that mean to you
three things have happened in my life
when I was thirty years old I got cancer
with metastasis a testicular cancer I
got the best treatment of the time and
here I'm sitting 66 years old that was
terrible I had two newly born children
you and I was going to die in the middle
of life losing your parents at age four
that's horrible for a child then my wife
and I lost a child from congenital
malformation the first day that was
deeply tragic it took ten to 20 years
before we could talk about that you know
and then my dear father got Alzheimer's
already at age 67 you know so the kids
really never had a grandfather he was
sort of lost and then he died out of
those through three things the first was
and the worst was cancer at age 30 the
second worst was losing a newborn the
third worst was losing the grandfather
but they're tremendously different the
order that you put those events in do
you think that connects to the order
that you prioritize you prioritize
middle middle of life and childhoods and
then which family wouldn't agree with me
biomedical science should not be guided
up to the old up here when we still have
so much problem down here take care of
the middle not go for the children and
if the resources are there then take the
one of the contentious points that's
been put to me is there are people who
are reaching beyond seventy to their 80s
and their 90s but they are not the
priority of focus that is if we're
choosing between and and somebody in
their 80s and somebody in their 50s
having a kidney transplant that for sure
it should be the person in their 50s now
I actually think that's very salacious
thinking because yeah if you make the
person at 50 survive then you owe this
person to also take care of them later
if you just have everybody survived to
65 and then you're like you're on your
own guys you can die now I mean what
kind of society is that I mean I think
that violates basically any ethical
standard that as scientists or
physicians or whatever we would have you
can't just say we have to choose between
the
the year olds and 85 years it's not like
that and this path is the part that
medical science is tackling what the
students here at this meeting are really
yes
the problem is that the money is up here
you know and the researchers when they
want to be applied have to go for where
the money is and that's like longer life
in the richest country among the elite
is an attractive subject to argue for so
it's fascinating to me that the older
scientists we've spoken to are concerned
with helping the younger people to live
longer and the younger scientists I'm
talking to are really interested in
aging and helping an aging population
aging affects us all we'll all lose
loved ones and possibly become infirm
ourselves clearly biomedical science can
make a huge difference but aging isn't a
disease like cancer it's inevitable and
maybe how we deal with this reality is
as much a personal social and political
question as it is a scientific one
you
we're here in lindau with 37 nobel
prize-winning scientists 600 young
researchers 12 of them sponsored by Mars
and people want to hear all about the
science that Mars has been doing well
the great thing about coming to lyndale
is that we get to spend time with
sciences rock stars you aware that
you're in the presence of greatness and
the more that we can find ways of
engaging some of the finest minds in the
world to helping us solve some of these
grand challenges and then there's got to
be some great stuff in
one of the things we do is we like to
have a lunch where we basically spend
time with the young scientists that
we've sponsored to come here and tell
them a little bit about the kind of
company that we are the kind of work
that we do and why we passionately
believe that these great scientists
should consider coming to a company like
Mars for a lifetime career in fun
science that will make the world a
better place
best part really is that you get to
actually meet these young scientists who
will look at you in the eye and say this
is the best week of my life
it is sitting at the Nobel laureate and
have a conversation that is a gift so we
have a science breakfast which is the
opportunity for us to host a discussion
around a very meaningful area of
research of healthy aging so we have Liz
Blackburn who won a Nobel Prize in this
field and we put her together with a
group of young scientists in a forum
facilitated by ourselves let's think
about the huge amount of years that
human lives are right so I made a little
scale bar for you on this high-tech
thing here this is a time scale what's
the maximum lifespan over a worm it goes
from here to here right of a fruit fly
from here to here now things get a bit
better okay let's go all the way out to
a mouse alright keep going keep going
okay we've got up to kindergarten we've
got decades and decades of life so the
science breakfasts are always great fun
highly interactive and a really good way
to have meaningful debate in an area of
public interest but also interest to
ourselves we're in middle age here so
maybe somebody's getting some diabetes
now I mean that's the thing it's not
just your lifespan this perhaps years of
living with chronic disease I think you
get the point right I'm just constantly
struck by how we have to be thinking in
terms of enormous timescales that these
things are the world is going to be
facing an aging population we're all
gonna get older and there's gonna be a
lot more of us who are old how do we
deal with that helping young scientists
realize that they can work with somebody
and realize that these are problems that
the world has to solve and business and
science can do it together
I think the private sector can play a
real role because this sort of research
that can be done by a company that isn't
necessarily related to just the
quarterly bottom line is the kind of
research that's complementary to what
governments can find I think Mars is a
good example of that so we got 37 Nobel
laureates here and just over 600 young
scientists and if we can play our role
in catalyzing some of the magic
happening between those two groups of
people then we go away very happy
you